you do a really good job i think of
going into grocery stores and pointing
out
things that are just
bad you know plain bad you actually i
just started using an oat brand that you
alerted everyone to what is that
chemical glyphosate phosphate i'm gonna
say it wrong you can speak to that much
better than i can
what can people do because when you when
you know about the stuff and you walk
into your average grocery store honestly
most of it is garbage most of the aisles
so how do you navigate that dietary
conversation first in a way that's
palatable to people and can make a
really big difference in their health
yeah i would say stop listening to gurus
on instagram and start listening to your
body
you know like i i can i i just as
quickly can open my instagram and see
someone saying
and i and i'm plant-based i'm vegan
saying vegan is the best diet you really
should be eating this type of food if
there's nothing better and if you want
to cure all disease do this and then the
next i could scroll down a little bit
and then two two frames later i'll see
someone saying
eating all meat will heal all your
disease it's the best of the best out
there if you have autoimmune disease
it's gonna reverse it this is the way
that our ancestors lived and
naturally so the common consumer
of social media is at a place where
they're like what do i do what you do
is turn off your phone and start being
in tune with your body right your body
knows better than me better than the
vegan influencer better than the
carnivore influencer and everyone in
between
what is right for you and how do you
tune into your body is when you're
eating and when you're ready to eat take
some time with your food right connect
with your food look at it breathe with
it right look around and see if you're
threatened by anything in your
environment and if you're not or if you
are go to a place where you feel safe
then be in that spot maybe turn off your
phone maybe turn off the tv and really
connect with your food you'll know very
quickly if this broccoli
these broccoli sprouts or this piece of
chicken liver is is good for your body
if you practice that over time you'll be
very much so in tune with what your body
wants to eat versus what it thinks it
should eat start there then when you go
to the supermarket
go for the whole food just go for the
foods that will spoil and and will rot
within a week right because those are
the foods that are alive then bring a
smaller amount and when i go back to
whole foods do all the colors of the
rainbow right red orange blue violet
green especially if you're getting
fruits and vegetables make sure you're
getting all of those colors because each
of those have different antioxidant
compounds different um different uh
proportions of them that are going to
affect your body in different ways
then make a smaller amount of your food
the pantry stuff right go in the middle
aisles make a small amount of food but
even in the middle aisles go for go for
the ingredients that you can read right
oh this has oat flour
sesame seeds black pepper a little bit
of garlic and maybe like
rice starch or something that seems
better than the one that has that plus
ten other items and flavors right you
see what i mean like if we can simplify
our food it's going to take a lot of
stress because there's way too much
noise on it can you speak to that
chemical that i addressed earlier that's
in the oats that seems to be something
that's kind of pervading a lot of boxed
food i actually recently got an alert
uh freeze-dry blueberries that i had
been buying for my kid a couple of years
ago had lid detected i mean some of
these packaged foods it can get pretty
scary even if the ingredients are
wholesome what are some things that you
found that have emerged in packaged food
that would inspire people to kind of
stay away from those and lean more
toward either packaged foods that have
some sort of process certification
process where chemicals have been
detected and weeded out or just whole
foods that you would see in your
vegetable and fruit aisle what's going
on with the packaged food that's the
most alarming right now
a few things uh
if we go conventional conventional the
food coloring is is a major issue
especially behaviorally especially for
children i mean i i grew up eating all
of the snack foods with all of the food
coloring you know from flintstones
gummies to fruit loops
to
cookies with all these different designs
and colors and flavors like
i was exposed to that now i thankfully
didn't have any behavioral disorders or
cognitive issues but that's one of the
insidious drivers especially for
children that we see so first and
foremost look at the food coloring here
in america it's the worst if you and i
were to get on a plane and go to europe
or switzerland you'd see that a lot of
the food coloring is used from food
right it's not synthetic it's natural so
say for example beets would give it that
that red violet color or turmeric would
give it that orange color
over here it's a little bit different
and they're used synthetically and
that's a problem so i would say food
coloring is one of the major issues that
you're seeing in a lot of these packaged
foods
glyphosate as you just mentioned is
coming in a lot of these conventional
non-organic foods so say for example you
have corn chips
that are non-organic and corn chips that
are organic the organic label is at
least and it's far from perfect very far
from perfect at least going to certify
to us that no genetically modified
organisms are used or that process isn't
used and glyphosate the herbicide the
pesticides the herbicide and pesticide
that is pervasive it's everywhere and
it's a problem it's a problem i don't
care what anyone says it is making
people sick and it's been making people
sick for a while
it has been expanding in agriculture for
many many years um
if if you ever and this is this will
pique everyone's interest
look into uh go online and type in the
monsanto papers these are papers that
were released by court order because
monsanto had missed the date montanto
bayer now montanto bear
are is the company that is
has developed glyphosate in roundup and
this is the chemical that is used in
everything from wheat to oats to corn to
soy to sugar
to sugar beets uh so much of our diet is
exposed to this stuff now if you look at
online after this go look at monsanto
papers what you'll see is a release of
these documents these are emails these
are what we found for monsanto's private
in-house information
contrary to what they say now monsanto
has been under so much scrutiny because
people
who have worked with roundup farmers
janitors have been developing
non-hodgkin's lymphoma this is a really
really nasty cancer that in fact that
attacks the lymphatic system right so
there's giant nodules that are growing
throughout the body
um
the people who are developing
non-hodgkin's lymphoma monsanto has
has consistently said it is not our it
is not due to roundup but when you see
these papers
it's obvious there's emails from the top
down administration not only admitting
that roundup causes non-hodgkin's
lymphoma but they know the mechanism as
to how it causes it this is beyond
anything that they publicize and this is
what we found out about the company we
found out that they know that they're
causing cancer
they don't care that they're causing
cancer and they actually know the
step-by-step process in the body
cellularly about how their chemical
is causing cancer it's the most
incredible thing that i've ever seen
when it comes to a company and a
corruption and this company bayer is
putting glyphosate into our food this is
why i say you've got to shop for organic
as much as you can especially if you're
getting corn soy canola which i don't
even recommend getting canola
sugar beets wheat
right oats all of these things need to
be organic uh other things like you know
you can you can go past you can get
carrots non-organic or or or lettuce or
spice or even spinach i'd recommend
getting more all produce organic but if
you can't afford it at least get the
foods that are sprayed with glyphosate
organic if you like the short clip you
can catch another one here or you can
catch the full episode right here